I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. It's party time, everybody. It's a launch party. Or is it a lunch party? How dare you? Is it a lunch party? Get out. You and Kevin can get out. That is one of my favorite jokes. Lounge party. Yeah, would that be better, Kevin? Would that be better for it to say launch party? Well, it is a launch party. It is another one-hour episode. So you know
我是詹娜·菲舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为您制作专属的《办公室》终极重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有亲历者才能告诉您的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室辣妈。大家派对时间到。这是一个发布会派对。还是一个午餐派对？你怎么敢这么说？这是一个午餐派对吗？滚出去。你和凯文都可以滚出去。这是我最喜欢的笑话之一。休息室派对。是的，那样会更好吗，凯文？发布会派对这个名字对它来说会更好吗？好吧，这确实是一个发布会派对。这又是长达一小时的一集。所以你知道
what that means. We're doing launch party part one today. This was season four episode five written by Jen Solada and directed by Ken Whittingham. I mean one of our favorite duos. Oh yeah. And this was actually Ken's sixth episode that he directed. We love Ken so much. I want you guys to know if you watch the bloopers, you will see a few times Jen and Ken cracking up and they whip the camera over on them and bust them. But they were just so fun on set, weren't they, Jenna? They were so like light and there for you and ready to laugh. I loved the two of them together. Same. All right, ladies, should I hit you up with a summary? Well, yeah, we got a lot to cover. So let's go. Well, here's what we're
这意味着什么。我们今天要看的是发布会派对（上集）。这是第四季第五集，由珍·索拉达编剧，肯·威丁汉执导。我是说，这是我们最喜欢的二人组之一。哦，是的。这实际上是肯执导的第六集。我们太喜欢肯了。我想让大家知道，如果你看了花絮，你会发现几次珍和肯笑得前仰后合，然后摄影机猛地转向他们并抓包了他们。但他们在片场真是太有趣了，对吧，詹娜？他们非常轻松，一直在支持你，随时准备大笑。我太喜欢他们俩在一起了。我也是。好吧，女士们，我要给你们讲讲剧情概要吗？好吧，是的，我们有很多内容要涵盖。那我们开始吧。好吧，以下是我们在
going to talk about this week. On the day of the Dunder Mifflin Infinity website launch, Dwight makes it his goal to beat the website and sales to impress Angela. Jim and Pam pranked Dwight into thinking the computer is communicating with him. And Michael thinks he got invited to the fancy launch party with sushi in New York. But he is embarrassed to learn he was only invited to attend virtually. Yeah, he was invited to a chat room, which he thought was a club that had a secret password. Exactly. The password is password. Yeah. Is there a WWW before that club name? Well, listen, this episode also features a very famous cold open from the series. You know the one I'm talking about, Angela. I do. I love it. And
这周要讨论的内容。在邓德·米弗林无限公司网站上线的当天，德怀特把击败网站销量作为他的目标，以此来给安吉拉留下深刻印象。吉姆和帕姆恶作剧地让德怀特以为电脑在和他交流。迈克尔以为他被邀请去纽约参加有寿司的高级发布会派对。但当他得知自己只是被邀请参加虚拟会议时，他感到很尴尬。是的，他被邀请到一个聊天室，而他以为那是一个有秘密密码的俱乐部。没错。密码就是密码。是的那个俱乐部名字前面有www吗？好吧，听着，这一集还包含该剧非常著名的冷开场。你知道我在说什么，安吉拉。我知道。我太喜欢了。而且
Jenna, I have had people write in and tell me that they do this in their office now. Yes. It sort of started a thing. When I watched this episode with Lee, he said, I've done this. I've done this. So it's the one that takes place in the conference room and everyone's watching this little DVD square on the screen behind Michael as he is trying to lecture us about I don't know what ideas to improve. Quarterly. Yeah. He's trying to tell us how to improve or spruce up the quarterlies, right? They're boring. Very boring. Well, we thought that today in lieu of fast facts, we should do a deep dive on this cold open. We should, you guys, because there's some fun, fun info for you. So we reached out to her writer,
詹娜，有人写信告诉我，他们现在在自己的办公室里也会这样做。是的。这算是一种潮流。我和李一起看这一集时，他说，我也做过这个。我也做过这个。所以，就是那个发生在会议室里的场景，大家都在看着迈克尔身后屏幕上的那个小DVD方块，而迈克尔正试图向我们发表长篇大论，我不知道是在讲什么改进意见。每季的。是的。他正试图告诉我们如何改进或美化每季报告，对吧？太无聊了。非常无聊。好吧，我们认为今天与其讲快速冷知识，不如对这个冷开场进行深入剖析。我们应该这样做，伙计们，因为这里有一些非常有趣的信息。所以我们联系了她的编剧，
Jen Salata, because we heard a rumor that this might have happened to her in her real life. It was somehow based on her, right, Jenna? Yes. And she had some great stuff to say. So let's do a deep dive with this cold open. Cold open deep dive, Sam. Will you play my son's sting? You've got a deep, you've got a dive. You put them together. Get it deep dive. There it is. There it is. All right. So like we said, Michael's having a meeting and behind him is this TV screen. And you don't really know what's going on at first because it just keeps panning around to everyone in the conference room and we are oddly riveted by what Michael is saying. Yeah. And what he's saying is so boring. Like he's saying,
珍·索拉达，因为我们听到一个传言，这可能在她的现实生活中发生过。这在某种程度上是以她为原型的，对吧，詹娜？是的。她有很多很棒的观点要分享。所以让我们对这个冷开场进行深入剖析吧。冷开场深度剖析，山姆。你能放一下我儿子的音效吗？你有深度，你有剖析。你把它们放在一起。听懂了吗，深度剖析。就是这样。就是这样。好吧。所以就像我们说的，迈克尔在开会，他身后是这个电视屏幕。你一开始真的不知道发生了什么，因为镜头一直在会议室里的每个人身上摇来摇去，而我们对迈克尔说的话感到离奇地着迷。是的。而且他说的话太无聊了。就像他在说，
I want to make suggestions to spruce up these quarterly reports. He's saying things like, what if in a bad quarter, there's a storm cloud or in a good quarter, there's fireworks or a race car. And then we all go, ugh. And he goes, not a race car. It doesn't have to be a race car. So then we go to this gym talking head and he explains what's going on. He says that they are all wanting to see if this little DVD cube on the TV screen will hit perfectly in the corner. And he says he doesn't think it can happen and that Pam claims she saw once when she was alone in the conference room. And then Jenna, it cuts to your talking head and you're so cute in this. You're like, I did see it. Did Jim say I didn't see it?
我想提出建议来美化这些季度报告。他说的话像是，如果在糟糕的季度，有一朵暴风雨云，或者在好的季度，有焰火或赛车。然后我们都发出，呃的声音。然后他说，不是赛车。不需要是赛车。然后我们切到吉姆的访谈镜头，他解释了发生了什么。他说他们都在看电视屏幕上的这个小DVD方块是否能完美地击中角落。他说他觉得这不可能发生，帕姆声称她有一次独自在会议室时看到过。然后詹娜，镜头切到你的访谈，你在这一幕里太可爱了。你说，我确实看到了。难道吉姆说我没看到吗？
It's very cute. It seems like we get to see a little joke between Jim and Pam. Yes. So then the boring meeting continues. And then finally it happens. The little cube goes in the square and everybody cheers and Michael thinks that it is because he has said something brilliant. Yeah. His whole where's Waldo thing was a big hit. And he's so happy. Michael is like, Hey, some days you just got it. Yeah. Some days you're just on fire. Yeah. Well, I remember shooting this Angela. It was so much fun. But it was also like something we had to choreograph. Do you remember? I do. And guys, it is true that this cold open was based on a real life experience of Jen Salata in the writer's room. And it was the
这非常可爱。看起来我们能看到吉姆和帕姆之间的一个小玩笑。是的。然后无聊的会议继续。最后，它发生了。小方块落入方块中，每个人都在欢呼，而迈克尔认为这是因为他说了一些精辟的话。是的。他那整套“在哪里寻找瓦尔多”的东西大受欢迎。他太高兴了。迈克尔就像是，嘿，有些日子你就是状态正佳。是的。有些日子你就是势不可挡。是的。嗯，我记得拍摄这个场景，安吉拉。太有趣了。但这也很像我们需要编排的东西。你还记得吗？我记得。伙计们，这个冷开场确实是以珍·索拉达在编剧室的真实生活经历为原型的，这是真的。这也是
inspiration for her writing this little cold open. We asked her about it. And here's what she had to say. So the inspiration for the cold open where the DVD logo bounces around the TV screen and everybody's transfixed was definitely the writer's room. I was obsessed with it. We would all watch the little DVD logo. And I remember that I saw it once hit perfectly in the corner that the edge of the logo lined up with the edge of the TV and it just felt so good. And I remember there was at least one non-believer in the room and it would hit like kind of close to the corner and they say that was it. That must be what you remember. It's not going to hit perfectly in the corner. And so I was transfixed
她写这个小冷开场的灵感来源。我们问过她这件事。以下是她的分享。所以冷开场的灵感——DVD标志在电视屏幕周围弹跳，每个人都看得出神——绝对来自编剧室。我对此着迷极了。我们都会盯着那个小DVD标志看。我记得我曾看到它有一次完美地击中角落，标志的边缘与电视机的边缘对齐了，那种感觉真是太爽了。而且我记得房间里至少有一个不相信的人，当它击中接近角落的地方时，他们会说，那就是了。这一定就是你记住的那样。它不会完美地击中角落的。所以我一直出神地盯着
with the logo and watching it a lot of the time and maybe not paying attention as much as I should have to the task at hand. So that is where the inspiration for it came from. So basically Jen was Pam. Yes. Jen was Pam and no one believed her and she was adamant about it and she wanted everyone else to see it go in the corner to like affirm her. This is what I love about Jen. If you guys have noticed you've been listening to our podcast, her episodes are so personal to her life experience. Yeah. I mean the WebMD thing, remember that she wrote about and now this and there's always these little moments from Jen's actual life and I think it is such a nice touch. And there are always these really ordinary moments that
标志看，大部分时间都在看它，可能没有像我对当前任务那样集中注意力。这就是灵感的来源。所以基本上，珍就是帕姆。是的。珍就是帕姆，没有人相信她，她对此非常坚决，她希望其他人看到它击中角落来证明自己。这就是我喜欢珍的地方。如果你们注意到并且一直在听我们的播客，她的剧集对她的人生经历来说非常个人化。是的。我是说，WebMD的那件事，还记得她写过那个，现在又有了这个，总是会有这些来自珍真实生活的小瞬间，我认为这真是一个很好的点缀。而且总是有这些非常普通的时刻，
might otherwise pass you by and something in her brain makes note of these. And that is why when you watch this cold open, it is so deeply relatable. It really is. I mean Jenna, you and I both tempt. We sat through boring meetings all the time and Jenna you do this. You find little hooks of something happening to get you through it. And it's like sometimes nothing you even like speak about with your other coworkers. You just all like lock onto something. I tempt at this office and all the executive side of the building face like a nice view of the city, but everyone in cubicles faced a parking garage. Okay. Okay. This parking garage became our entertainment. Like every day it'd be like, what's happening
否则可能会被你忽略，而她大脑中的某个部分注意到了这些。这就是为什么当你观看这个冷开场时，它是如此引人共鸣。真的如此。我是说詹娜，你和我都有过临时工经历。我们一直都在熬无聊的会议，詹娜你也是这样。你会寻找一些小小的钩子来帮自己度过难关。这就像有时甚至不是你和同事谈论的内容。你们只是都锁定在某个东西上。我在这个办公室做过临时工，大楼里所有行政人员的一侧面向美丽的城市景观，但隔间里的每个人都面对着停车场。好吧。好吧。这个停车场成了我们的娱乐活动。就像每天都会说，停车场里发生了什么？
in the parking garage? And they'd be like, oh, you remember blue zippy guy? You know blue zippy guy? He always zips around in that blue Toyota. Oh yeah, blue zippy guy got a new car. What? No. Yeah. And then one day, oh my gosh, it was like it ate up our whole day. There was a couple that would meet in the parking lot at lunch. Lady, I shit you not. It was like their meetup place. What? And yes, they would pull up in two cars and we'd be like, Oh, they're here. They're here. And then they would get in one car and they would talk. Sometimes they would kiss nothing, nothing more than just like a smoocher to but we became so invested in the parking lot couple. They were having an affair. That must have been
他们会说，哦，你还记得蓝色飞驰哥吗？你知道蓝色飞驰哥吗？他总是开着那辆蓝色丰田到处飞驰。哦，是的，蓝色飞驰哥买新车了。什么？没有。是的。然后有一天，天哪，这简直占用了我们一整天的时间。有一对情侣会在午餐时间在停车场见面。女士，我没骗你。这就像是他们的约会地点。什么？是的，他们会开两辆车过来，我们会说，哦，他们来了。他们来了。然后他们会坐进一辆车里聊天。有时他们会接吻，没别的，也就是接吻或者什么的，但我们对停车场情侣投入了太多的感情。他们肯定是在偷情。那绝对是
an affair. Why do you why would you meet up in a parking garage and in two separate cars and then get into one car and like smooching stuff? If you're not like sneaking around, that is not normal. I guess you're right. Unless it's like their lunch break or something. I don't know. It was around lunch and sometimes they would eat lunch together. So I thought, well, maybe they're a couple. Oh, well, then maybe they're a couple. I don't know. But also maybe it was Todry. I don't know. But one day they got in a fight. Oh, we didn't know what it was about. We saw like sort of like hand like, you know, you can tell body energy in the car. And then he got out and he slimmed the door and he kind of like leaned
偷情。为什么你要在停车场见面，开两辆车，然后坐进一辆车里接吻之类的？如果你不是在偷偷摸摸，那太不正常了。我想你是对除非这是他们的午餐时间什么的。我不知道。大概是午餐时间，有时他们会一起吃午饭。所以我想，嗯，也许他们是一对。哦，好吧，那也许他们是一对。我不知道。但也许这也挺无聊的。我不知道。但有一天他们吵架了。哦，我们不知道是为了什么。我们看到那种像是挥手——你知道的，你能看出车里的身体能量。然后他下车，砰地关上车门，然后靠在车后座上
back on the back. I'm telling you, this is all we could think about. We couldn't think about any of the like work we were supposed to be doing. We're like, oh, he is pissed. Have you seen? He's leaning up on the back of the car. Have you seen him? Oh, there goes blue zippy guy. That couple that parking garage was your DVD square. Yes. Yes. But this is what I love about Jen is these little tiny moments that are so relatable when you work in an office all day. You have to find little things to get you through. Absolutely. Well, Angela, you mentioned that when we were shooting this, it was really technical and we got a lot of fan questions about it. Oh, let's hear them. All right. Sandy P, Megan S, Miranda
向后靠。我告诉你，这就是我们脑子里想的一切。我们根本无法思考任何本该去做的工作。我们在想，哦，他气炸了。你看到了吗？他正靠在车尾。你看见他了吗？哦，蓝色飞驰哥走了。那对情侣，那个停车场就是你的DVD方块。是的。是的。但这就是我喜欢珍的地方，这些微小的时刻是如此引人共鸣，当你在办公室工作一整天时。你必须找到一些小事来帮你度过难关。绝对的。好吧，安吉拉，你提到当我们拍摄这一幕时，技术性非常强，我们收到了很多粉丝关于它的提问。哦，让我们听听。好吧。桑迪·P、梅根·S、米兰达
D, Mo Downey and Amanda McKnight all asked, how in the world did you time the cube to go in the corner at exactly the right moment? Did the show need to create like a special program for the DVD screensaver? You know, Angela, when I watched this, I have to say I was kind of amazed and I could not remember how we did it. I thought, did they make like a DVD disc and we had to time it all out? Yeah, I sort of remembered Ken Whittingham giving us cues. Did you remember that? Oh, like hand signals of when to cheer or when to be shocked or all of our reactions. Yeah, but I can't be sure. I feel like Ken was giving us hand signals, but you know what? We asked Jen and she had a little something to say
·D、莫·唐尼和阿曼达·麦克奈特都问，到底怎么把时间掐得那么准，让方块在恰好的时刻击中角落的？节目组是不是需要为DVD屏保专门编写一个特殊的程序？你知道，安吉拉，当我看到这一幕时，我不得不说我有点惊讶，我记不清我们是怎么做到的了。我想，他们是不是制作了一个DVD光盘，然后我们必须把时间全都掐准？是的，我隐约记得肯·威丁汉给我们打手势。你还记得吗？哦，像是手势，什么时候欢呼，什么时候表现出震惊，或者我们所有的反应。是的，但我不能确定。我觉得肯在给我们打手势，但你知道吗？我们问了珍，她对此有一些看法。
about it. So I couldn't remember how we actually filmed the DVD logo part of the scene. So I asked Dave Rogers who edited the episode and he said that we put the DVD screensaver in later. It was burned in later. So it was just a blue screen on the monitor while we were filming, which allowed us to play with the timing of when the logo would hit the edges of the TV. Yes. That makes so much sense. There was nothing on the TV. Nothing. And I think Ken was telling us like either like thumbs up to cheer or thumbs down. And we had certain words that Steve was going to say is Michael, right? That we knew. Well, I definitely remember that. I remember that Steve's dialogue was written and this was
所以我不记得我们实际是怎么拍摄场景中DVD标志部分的了。于是我问了负责剪辑这一集的戴夫·罗杰斯，他说我们是后来才把DVD屏保放进去的。它是后来烧录进去的。所以在拍摄时监视器上只是一块蓝屏，这让我们能够掌控标志击中电视边缘的时间节奏。是的。这太合情合理了。电视上什么都没有。什么都没有。而且我想肯当时在给我们指示，比如竖起大拇指表示欢呼，或者竖起大拇指向下。我们有一些史蒂夫要说的台词，作为迈克尔，对吧？我们知道的。好吧，我绝对记得这一点。我记得史蒂夫的台词是写好的，这
unusual because a lot of times we would get in these conference room scenes and we could play around and we could improvise, but not with this because it was too important that we react off of certain things he said. Yeah. And we all had to react at the same time. So it was very sort of like planned out. Well, we also asked Jen about writing this dialogue and here's what she had to say. As far as dialogue for Steve in the cold open, I remember trying to match the dialogue with the reactions that everybody was having to the much more important DVD logo in the background. Steve always makes everything better. So it's possible that some of the dialogue was changed a bit or just made better. But I remember when we
很不寻常，因为很多时候我们进入这些会议室场景时可以随意发挥，也可以即兴创作，但这个不行，因为根据他说的一些特定事情做出反应太重要了。是的。而且我们都必须同时做出反应。所以这非常像是计划好的。好吧，我们还问了珍关于编写这段台词的事情，以下是她的分享。至于冷开场中史蒂夫的台词，我记得我试图将台词与每个人对背景中那个更重要的DVD标志的反应相匹配。史蒂夫总是能让一切变得更好。所以某些台词可能稍微做过修改，或者只是变得更好，这是有可能的。但我记得当我们
were filming it, we also with the camera that was on you guys, we had you guys have various reactions so that we could just have them and Dave could edit them in like just the crazy joy that you'd feel when it hit the corner and how frustrating it would be when it missed so that we had a bunch of reactions to play with that we could end up giving to Dave at the end when he was trying to assemble the scene. I thought it timed out so wonderfully and captured the excitement of when that cube hits the corner. And I just love so much how Steve plays the fact that he thinks that everything is about him completely unbeknownst to him. The terribly exciting thing that's happening behind him. That is so much technical
拍摄时，针对拍你们的摄像机，我们让你们做出了各种反应，这样我们就能把这些录下来，戴夫就能把它们剪辑进去——比如当它击中角落时你会感到的那种狂喜，以及当它错过时会是多么令人沮丧——这样我们就有很多反应素材可以在最后戴夫试图组合这个场景时交给他。我觉得时间掐得太棒了，完美捕捉到了当那个方块击中角落时的兴奋感。我太喜欢史蒂夫如何完全浑然不觉地认为一切都与他有关。而他身后正在发生那么令人兴奋的事情。这其中包含了大量技术性
work that went into making this happen. And by the way, Jen sent us a picture of all of us from our point of view looking at that blue blank TV screen. So we'll post that in the pod. Yeah, that is so great. And what a fun thing that Jen's little idea this thing that happened to her ended up being this fantastic cold open and there is your deep dive of this episode's cold open. I loved it. I don't know. I enjoyed learning all those things about it myself and I was there. I feel like we say that a lot. We're like, oh my God, and we were there and that is so cool and I didn't know that. That's how I feel when I rewatch the show sometimes. Sometimes I'm like, but I was there. I'm in that room. That's me.
工作才让这一切成为现实。顺便说一句，珍给我们发了一张照片，是我们所有人的视角看着那个蓝色空白电视屏幕的样子。所以我们会把它发到播客里。是的，真是太棒了。珍的小点子——她身上发生的事情——最终变成了这个精彩的冷开场，这是一件多么有趣的事，这就是本集冷开场的深度剖析。我太喜欢了。不知道，我自己了解所有这些关于它的事情也很享受，而我当时就在现场。我觉得我们经常这么说。我们会说，哦天哪，我们当时就在现场，这太酷了，我以前都不知道。有时候我重温这部剧时也是这种感觉。有时候我会想，但我当时就在现场。我就在那个房间里。那是我。
I did that. I did that. Exactly. All right. Well, lady, I feel like we should go to break and then we'll come back and let's get into this episode. We'll break it down. Break it down, break it down. Okay, we are back for a launch party and Jenna, before we get into this, I just want you to know something. I think I might have found your soulmate. Now look, I know you're happily married and Lee, I apologize, but there's something Jenna needs to know. Jenna, Paul Reiser star of NBC sitcom, Mad about you might be your soulmate. Why are you saying this? He did an interview with the AV club recently where he said, and I quote, well, I just won't watch Game of Thrones. Oh, wait, it gets better. He says,
我做到了。我做到了。没错。好吧，女士们，我觉得我们该去休息一下，然后回来深入探讨这一集。我们会剖析它。剖析它，剖析它。好的，我们回来继续聊发布会派对。詹娜，在我们深入探讨之前，我只是想让你知道一件事。我想我可能找到你的灵魂伴侣了。听着，我知道你婚姻幸福，里奇，我向你道歉，但詹娜有些事必须知道。詹娜，NBC情景喜剧《我疯狂为你》的主演保罗·雷瑟可能是你的灵魂伴侣。你为什么这么说？他最近接受《AV俱乐部》采访时说，我引用一下，“嗯，我就是不看《权力的游戏》。”哦，等等，后面更精彩。他说，
it doesn't come up that often. Nobody's lobbying for me to watch it, but there are certain things that I have learned that I just am not interested in. No matter how many times you tell me it's good, I can't. Are you ready? Uh huh. Then he goes on to say, like last year, I went on Jimmy Fallon with Helen Hunt and I didn't mean for this to be public, but you know, they asked, what are you doing for Christmas? And Helen said, I'm going to go home and watch the new Star Wars movie. And Jimmy said, what about you? And I said, here's the truth. Oh no. I've never seen one. And the audience gasped like I had said, I strangled a puppy. He said, I've seen pieces. I know what they look like, but it's not for me.
这不经常出现。没有人游说我去看它，但有些事情我已经了解到，我就是对它们不感兴趣。不管你告诉我多少次它有多好看，我都做不到。你准备好了吗？嗯哼。然后他接着说，“就像去年，我和海伦·亨特一起上了吉米·法伦的节目，我本无意公开此事，但你知道，他们问，你圣诞节打算做什么？海伦说，我要回家看新的《星球大战》电影。吉米说，你呢？我说，实话实说吧。”哦，不。我从来没看过。然后观众倒吸一口气，就像我说我勒死了一只小狗一样。他说，“我看过片段。我知道它们长什么样，但这不适合我。
I'm not degrading it. They're clearly very good. I'm going to skip it. Oh, my God. Okay. I am forming a dinner party for myself. I'm going to bring Paul Reiser and then I got to bring John Favreau because I just watched him make some sourdough from scratch. He was but John Favreau is doing the Mandalorian. He clearly loves Star Wars. This is a horrible dinner party. Do you want conflict at dinner? Oh my gosh, you're so right. Invite me. I'll be the buffer. Okay. Between you and John Favreau. But I love that Paul Reiser said, I'm going to skip it. Oh my gosh. I got so tickled when I read that. I like I've been saving that. I couldn't wait to share it with you. I hope that I run into him one day so
我不是在贬低它。它们显然非常好看。我要跳过它。”哦，天哪。好吧。我要为自己组办一个晚宴。我要请来保罗·雷瑟，然后我还得请来约翰·法夫罗，因为我刚看他从头制作了一些酸面包。但他约翰·法夫罗正在制作《曼达洛人》。他显然很喜欢《星球大战》。这是一个糟糕的晚餐派对。你想在晚餐时发生冲突吗？哦天哪，你太对了。邀请我吧。我会当缓冲垫。好吧。在你和约翰·法夫罗之间。但我喜欢保罗·雷瑟说，“我要跳过它。”天哪。我读到那段时觉得太逗了。我就像是一直把它存着。我迫不及待地想跟你分享。我希望有一天能偶遇他，
that we can discuss this. We're part of a very small group of people, but there's more of us out there. I've gotten mail. There's more of us out there who just do not connect to that material. Oh my gosh. And it's very validating to hear from others. I just bought myself a shirt with Baby Yoda on it. See, I think Baby Yoda is very cute. I just maybe don't want to watch a whole show about it. But I'll hang the ornament on my tree in a hot second, you know? Well, Baby Yoda got a name and everyone's a buzz about it, but I know you don't care. Well, what is that? GroGoo, G-R-O-G-U, GroGoo. GroGoo? GroGoo is his name. Okay. Okay, Paul Reiser. I'm going to skip it. That's that. You know what?
这样我们就可以讨论这件事了。我们是一小撮人的一部分，但外面还有更多这样的人。我收到过信。外面还有更多人就是无法与那个题材产生共鸣。哦，天哪。听到别人的心声感觉非常得到肯定。我刚刚给自己买了一件印有尤达宝宝的衬衫。看，我觉得尤达宝宝非常可爱。我可能只是不想看一整部关于它的剧集。但我会在一秒钟内把装饰品挂在我的树上，你知道吗？嗯，尤达宝宝有了名字，每个人都在议论纷纷，但我知道你不在乎。那是什么？格古，G-R-O-G-U，格古。格古？格古是他的名字。好吧。好吧，保罗·雷瑟。我要跳过它。就是这样。你知道吗？
That was some serious PR energy. I'm going to skip it. What's PR? Paul Reiser energy. I just love that he ends it with, I'm going to skip it. It's so beautiful. It's perfect. Well, maybe we should get into this episode. Okay. I just wanted you to know that I found your soulmate. Anyway, let's get to the episode. You guys, this episode starts with a fantastic scene. Kay Flannery and John Krasinski crushed this. I was laughing so hard. It's all so good. John's tiny little moments are amazing. So Meredith kind of is like being flirty with Jim. She's like, hey, thanks for visiting me at the hospital. And he's like, well, we, we all came to see you. And she's like, yeah. And then she wants him to sign her cast and
那是相当严重的公关能量。我要跳过它。什么是PR？保罗·雷瑟能量（Paul Reiser energy）。我太喜欢他以“我要跳过它”结尾了。太美妙了。太完美了。好吧，也许我们该进入这一集了。好吧。我只是想让你知道我找到了你的灵魂伴侣。不管怎样，我们进入这一集吧。伙计们，这一集开场是一个极棒的场景。凯·弗兰纳里和约翰·卡拉辛斯基演得太绝了。我笑得太厉害了。这一切都太棒了。约翰的小小瞬间太惊艳了。所以梅雷迪思有点在对吉姆调情。她说，嘿，谢谢你来医院看我。他说，嗯，我们，我们都来看你了。她说，是啊。然后她想让他签她的石膏，
she pulls up her skirt and leans her pelvis into him. Yeah. And Jim is like, okay, no one else has signed it. No one. She doesn't ask anybody else to sign it. I know. She wanted one signature and she wanted it where she could see it when she gets home. Oh, Lord. I have a question. Okay. We got a lot of fan questions about this scene, but I'm going to start with my question. Do you get a cast on your pelvis when you break your pelvis? Is that even a thing? Should I have looked it up? I guess we should have looked it up. I didn't think to question it, but now that you mention it, it looks like cast undies. How do you sit in that? How do you go to the bathroom? I had a lot of questions. Okay.
她撩起裙子，把骨盆向他靠过去。吉姆说，好吧，没别人签名了。没别人。她没让任何人签名。我知道。她想要一个签名，而且她想要在她回家后能看到的地方。哦，天哪。我有个问题。好吧。我们收到了很多粉丝关于这个场景的提问，但我先从我的问题开始。当你骨盆骨折时，骨盆上会打石膏吗？这甚至是一种真实的做法吗？我是不是该查一下？我想我们应该查一下。我当时没想过质疑它，但既然你提到了，它看起来像是石膏内裤。你怎么坐在那上面？你怎么上厕所？我有很多问题。好吧。
Do we need a real time deep dive on pelvic casts? I'm looking it up right now. Do you get a cast when I'm typing in on your pelvis? Oh God, what's going to come up? You know, I'll tell you what, Angela, I have a lot of weird searches because of this podcast. Oh, well, I know that. If someone were investigating me, they would be very, very confused by my search history. I know. I think that all the time. Okay. So this doctor says it's like a rib. You can't cast ribs. We don't cast pelvic fractures according to Dr. Rothberg. Is that correct, internet? That's what Dr. Rothberg says. Well, Cody is messaging us that she's seeing the same thing, that you cannot cast a pelvis. This was similar to
我们需要对骨盆石膏进行实时深度剖析吗？我正在查这个。打石膏当我在打字时……在你的骨盆上？哦天哪，会搜出什么来？你知道吗，安吉拉，因为这个播客，我有很多奇怪的搜索记录。哦，好吧，我知道。如果有人在调查我，他们会被我的搜索历史搞得非常非常困惑。我知道。我一直这么想。好吧。所以这个医生说这就像一根肋骨。你不能给肋骨打石膏。根据罗斯伯格医生的说法，我们不会给骨盆骨折打石膏。互联网，这是真的吗？这就是罗斯伯格医生说的。好吧，科迪发信息给我们说她看到了同样的情况，你不能给骨盆打石膏。这类似于
my back fracture. You can't cast it. It's like a rib break. All right. Well, moving on to our fan questions on this one then. Okay. Hannah Baumgartner, Megan Robinson, Miriam Humphrey, Miranda Dunham, Alice and Ellis, and many others said, first of all, how many casts did they make for Meredith? And did John Krasinski sign his real name on this cast because it really looks like he wrote John Krasinski instead of Jim Halpert? And Charmaine Marshall asked, did anyone keep Meredith's cast? Oh, we know the answers to all of that. We reached out to Kate Flannery, the wearer of the cast undies. And here's what she had to say. Kate Flannery here to clear up any mystery
我的背部骨折。你不能打石膏。这就像肋骨骨折。好吧。那我们接下来看粉丝提问吧。好吧。汉娜·鲍姆加特纳、梅根·罗宾逊、米里亚姆·汉弗莱、米兰达·邓纳姆、艾莉森·埃利斯和许多其他人说，首先，他们为梅雷迪思做了多少个石膏？约翰·卡拉辛斯基在这个石膏上签的是他的真名吗，因为看起来他写的确实是“约翰·卡拉辛斯基”而不是“吉姆·霍尔珀特”？查曼·马歇尔问，有人留着梅雷迪思的石膏吗？哦，我们知道所有这些答案。我们联系了石膏内裤的穿着者凯·弗兰纳里。以下是她的分享。凯·弗兰纳里在这里澄清有关梅雷迪思骨盆石膏的任何谜团。
around Meredith's pelvis cast. First question, did they have more than one cast? Yes. I actually had to come in especially and we did about eight casts. I literally had to lie down on my back wearing a pair of tidy whiteies over my clothes. And then they did these like cast strips that they got wet with like plaster Paris, and they built the front of it. So I had an elastic waistband, and I had to pull it off before it got too hard. That's what she said. And I remember doing my space post about it, because I had a blog as Meredith, and I wrote a whole thing that said, Meredith gets plastered. It just writes itself, doesn't it? I do remember doing multiple takes, although we did get it on the first one, except for the fact that John accidentally signed his
第一个问题，他们不止做一个石膏吗？是的。我实际上不得不专程过来，我们做了大约八个石膏。我真的不得不躺在背上，衣服外面穿着一条白色三角裤。然后他们做了这些石膏条，用石膏粉弄湿，然后把它堆在前面。所以我有一个松紧腰带，我必须在它变硬之前把它扯下来。她就是这么说的。我记得我发过关于它的太空博客，因为我当时以梅雷迪思的身份写了一个博客，我写了一整篇文章说，梅雷迪思喝醉了（Meredith gets plastered）。这简直不言而喻，对吧？我确实记得拍了很多条，尽管我们在第一条就拍成了，除了约翰不小心签了
real name instead of Jim Halpert. And that is the one that I kept. I still have my pelvis cast. I made a coffee table out of it. No, I don't know what to do with it. It's in my closet right now, but should I hang it on the wall? I don't know what to do. It's so good. Maybe it should be a coffee table, maybe a looseite box, like an art piece in the shrine that is the office in my house. Anyway, I hope I answered your questions. Bye. I vote for looseite box. I would so want that as a coffee table. I mean, it's a conversation starter. It really is. Well, you know, when Kate stopped by our little Zoom chat, she showed us, she held up the cast, and there it is. She's got it, and John signed it. And if you're rewatching the episode at two minutes, 42 seconds, you can see
他的真名而不是吉姆·霍尔珀特。而那正是我留下的那个。我还留着我的骨盆石膏。我用它做了一个咖啡桌。不，我不知道该拿它怎么办。它现在就在我的衣柜里，但我是不是该把它挂在墙上？我不知道该怎么办。太棒了。也许它应该是一张咖啡桌，也许是一个透明亚克力盒子，就像我家里办公室神殿里的一件艺术品。总之，希望我回答了你们的问题。拜拜。我投票给透明亚克力盒子。我太想要那个做咖啡桌了。我是说，这是一个能开启对话的话题。确实如此。好吧，你知道的，当凯来到我们的Zoom群聊时，她给我们展示了，她举起了那个石膏，就是那个。她留着它，而且约翰签了名。如果你在两分42秒重温这一集，你可以看到
John's signature plain as day. Well, I love knowing that that was the first take and that they used it anyway. They nailed it on the first take. Their performance was so good that when they got in the editing room, they were like, we don't care that you signed John Krasinski. We need this performance. It's too good. Yeah, I also think that was the first time, you know, because in rehearsal, Kate would not have lifted her skirt or any of that, right? Yeah. So that was the first time John is Jim, like, had to see all of it in his reactions were so honest of like, oh, God, oh, she's lifting her skirt. Here we go. Well, we got another fan question, Angela, from Caitlin Oliver, who noticed Meredith is wearing a purplish eye shadow. Oh, yeah.
约翰的签名一清二楚。好吧，我很高兴知道那是第一条，而且他们无论如何都用了它。他们在第一条就拿下了。他们的表演太棒了，当他们进入剪辑室时，他们会想，我们才不管你签的是约翰·卡拉辛斯基呢。我们需要这段表演。太棒了。是的，我也觉得那是第一次，你知道的，因为在排练时，凯是不会撩起裙子或做那些动作的，对吧？是的。所以那是约翰作为吉姆第一次不得不看到这一切，他的反应太真实了，像是，哦，天哪，哦，她撩起裙子了。我们上吧。好吧，我们收到了另一个粉丝提问，安吉拉，来自凯特琳·奥利弗，她注意到梅雷迪思戴着紫色的眼影。哦，是的。
She looks kind of cute today. Is this because she's back in the office or did she dress up specifically for Jim because she planned on hitting on him? Oh, I love to think she dressed up for Jim. But I noticed that too. Her makeup had a little bit of a jush to it. Yeah, I noticed it as well. I like Caitlin's theory. I do too. Well, Caitlin, you'd probably love to know that at two minutes, 55 seconds, there is a fabulous shot of the plant at front reception. Tell me more. Well, there's a stripy pot. Stripy pot is back. Multicolored stripy pot. I remember it. So we are recycling pots. And this is a big leafy plant. We'll see how long it lasts. I need to reach out to I don't know who it would be. Someone on Michael Gallenberg's team. I need to reach out
她今天看起来挺可爱的。这是因为她回到了办公室，还是她专门为吉姆精心打扮的，因为她打算勾引他？哦，我喜欢认为她是为吉姆打扮的。但我也注意到了。她的妆容确实稍微做过修饰。是的，我也注意到了。我喜欢凯特琳的理论。我也是。好吧，凯特琳，你可能会喜欢知道在两分55秒时，前台的植物有一个极棒的镜头。告诉我更多。嗯，有一个条纹花盆。条纹花盆回来了。多色条纹花盆。我记得它。所以我们在循环利用花盆。这是一株叶子茂盛的大植物。我们要看看它能坚持多久。我需要联系——我不知道会是谁。迈克尔·加伦贝格团队的某个人。我需要联系
to him and get more information on the plants who specifically some person on our crew was in charge of those plants each week. I need to know more. Yeah. Yeah. I would love that. Oh my god. You know how happy I'd be to do a deep dive on Pam's plants. Get out. All right. This is my new mission. We're on it. We're on it. We're on it. Well, also, I want to put something on your radar for this episode. We're going to track it. We're going to track the short jokes, Jenna. There's so many. There's so many. I was texting with Jen Salata last night about it. What up with the short jokes? We'll get to it. So, all right. Pam, hands Michael a press release. It's a big day in this office, okay? Michael announces that he's going to New York to attend the
他并获取有关植物的更多信息，具体是剧组中的某个人负责每周照料这些植物。我想知道更多。是的。是的。我太喜欢了。哦天哪。你知道我对帕姆的植物做深度剖析会有多高兴吗？滚开。好吧。这是我的新任务。我们开始吧。我们开始吧。我们开始吧。好吧，另外，我想把一件事放进你这一集的雷达里。我们要追踪它。我们要追踪矮个笑话，詹娜。太多了。太多了。我昨晚还在和珍·索拉达发短信聊这个。矮个笑话是怎么回事？我们待会儿会讲到。所以，好吧。帕姆递给迈克尔一份新闻稿。今天是办公室里的大日子，好吗？迈克尔宣布他要去纽约参加
party with all the important people. Yep. The non-important people are going to be at these satellite parties. And now we also find out that Dunder Mifflin Infinity, the website, will be launching. Yes. And there is a moment when Michael says, hey, I'm going to the fancy party. So, if any of you guys have any good stories for me, you know, that I can talk about at the party, let me know. There is a shot of Creed. The camera zooms in and Creed's nodding like, yes, at like three minutes, 21 seconds. Yep. Jenna, this would have cut to a deleted scene where Creed goes in and pitches stories to Michael. No. Are you serious? Yes. I am serious. And he talks about like a guy with a bird and then someone jumps in the river and Michael's like,
汇集了所有重要人物的派对。是的。不重要的人会参加这些卫星派对。现在我们还发现，邓德·米弗林无限公司，也就是那个网站，将要上线了。是的。有一个时刻，迈克尔说，嘿，我要去那个高级派对。所以，如果你们谁有好的故事讲给我听，你知道的，我可以拿到派对上去聊，告诉我。镜头给到了克里德。摄像机拉近，克里德在点头，表示同意，大约在三分21秒。是的。詹娜，这本会切到一个被删减的场景，克里德在里面向迈克尔推销故事。不。你是认真的吗？是的。我是认真的。他讲了一个关于一个带着鸟的人的故事，然后有人跳进河里，迈克尔说，
this is a great story. And Creed's like, oh, no, no, no, you can never tell this. Oh, no. But it Creed had some fun stuff in this episode that's in the deleted scenes. Oh, that's so good. I know. And then we have this great talking head by Michael where he says, Dunder Mifflin Infinity is the brainchild of his brainchild, Ryan. So therefore, this whole idea, Jenna, is Michael's brain grandchild. It is. And he's so proud of it. He's so proud of it. I mean, he basically did it. Yeah. If you really think about it. Yeah. Well, as Michael is continuing to share with the group, he mentions that Dunder Mifflin is expecting record high sales and that they are anticipating that the website will become the
这是一个很棒的故事。然后克里德说，哦，不，不，不，你绝对不能讲这个。哦，不。但克里德在这一集里有一些有趣的素材，在删减片段里。哦，太棒了。我知道。然后迈克尔有一个很棒的访谈，他说邓德·米弗林无限公司是他亲信赖安的智慧结晶。所以因此，整个创意，詹娜，就是迈克尔的脑细胞孙子。是的。他太为此自豪了。他太自豪了。我是说，基本上就是他做出来的。是的。如果你仔细想想的话。是的。嗯，正当迈克尔继续与大家分享时，他提到邓德·米弗林预计销售额将创新高，他们预计该网站将成为公司里
new best salesman at the company. Well, this really bumps Dwight. Yeah. Dwight does not want to be beaten by a website. So Dwight is going to challenge the website to a sales competition. And he's like trying to impress Angela. She's like, it's a waste of time. Oh, shorty joke, number one. Angela's like, it's a waste of time. Michael says, what's that pipsqueak? There it is. Number one. So Jen Salada was saying, she doesn't think she wrote any of these high jokes. And I told her that Steve used to love as Michael to like comment on my size. Yeah. And I know, in fact, the next one we're going to talk about was improvised. But yes, I also loved in the scene, Jenna, that as Michael's reading the memo, Kelly's like, did Ryan mention if he's in
新的最佳销售员。嗯，这真的让德怀特很不爽。是的。德怀特可不想被一个网站打败。所以德怀特要向网站发起销售竞赛。他正试图给安吉拉留下深刻印象。她却说，这纯属浪费时间。哦，矮个笑话一号。安吉拉说，这纯属浪费时间。迈克尔说，你说什么呢，小矮人？就是这样。一号。所以珍·索拉达说，她不觉得这些身高笑话是她写的。而我告诉她，史蒂夫以前很喜欢作为迈克尔来评论我的身材。是的。我知道，事实上，我们接下来要谈的下一个是即兴发挥的。但是的，我也很喜欢在这个场景中，詹娜，当迈克尔在读备忘录时，凯莉说，瑞安有没有提到他是不是在恋爱中？
a relationship? Yes, is that in the memo? Does the memo say anything about if he's in a relationship? The corporate memo. Yeah. Well, we had a fan question about this scene from Chris Martins and Wyatt Hensley. They said, Dwight has a beard. Is that rain's real facial hair? And how long was the break between episodes for him to grow this facial hair? They also want to know is the unshaven facial hair supposed to show how distraught Dwight is without Angela? Well, I can tell you that this double was totally thought out. It was a plot point that Dwight is really distraught from his breakup. And he's kind of let himself go. And there was a talking head that would have supported this. There's a talking head at the beginning of the day, Dwight comes in and Jim kind of takes
是的，备忘录里有这个吗？备忘录里有没有提到他是不是在恋爱中？公司备忘录。嗯。好吧，我们收到了一位粉丝关于这个场景的提问，来自克里斯·马丁斯和怀亚特·亨斯利。他们说，德怀特留了胡子。那是雷恩的真实面部毛发吗？为了长出这脸毛，两集之间给他放了多长时间的假？他们还想问，没刮干净的面部毛发是不是为了表现失去安吉拉后德怀特的沮丧？嗯，我可以告诉你，这个胡茬完全是深思熟虑过的。这是一个剧情点，德怀特因分手而感到非常沮丧。而且他有点自暴自弃了。本来有一个访谈可以支撑这一点。有一场开场时的访谈，德怀特走进来，吉姆对他的样子有点
a double take at him. And he's like, what's up with the stubble? And he's like, Friday you left nothing, Monday you have stubble. So now we know this episode's on a Monday, right? But Dwight just looks at him and goes, I'm a man, Jim. And he's like, okay, all right, buddy. And then Dwight has a whole talking head. And he says, yeah, I stopped shaving because my girlfriend broke up with me. And he talks about how he's in pain. And it's comedic. But basically, he's saying, my girlfriend broke up with me and it sucks. Yeah. So it was scripted that he would have this facial stubble, but that part got cut out. So then sort of leaves you wondering. But guys, in answer to the other question, there was just like in this deleted scene, a standard weekend
多看了一眼。他说，你这胡茬是怎么回事？他说，周五你还没长胡子，周周围你就有胡茬了。所以现在我们知道这一集发生在周一，对吧？但德怀特只是看着他说，我是个男人，吉姆。吉姆说，好吧，好吧，伙计。然后德怀特有一整段访谈。他说，是的，我不再刮胡子了，因为我女朋友和我分手了。他谈到自己有多痛苦。这很滑稽。但基本上，他是在说，我女朋友和我分手了，这太糟糕了。是的。所以剧本里写了他是会有这种面部胡茬的，但那部分被剪掉了。所以这就留给你去猜想了。但伙计们，作为对另一个问题的回答，这就像在这个删减片段中一样，只是一个标准的周末
break. So we would shoot Monday through Friday and rain just had the weekend to grow this stubble. It's his real facial hair. The thing though that gets difficult is matching it every day throughout the week. So on Monday, he came in with the stubble, but then they would have to match that exact length on Tuesday, Wednesday, Thursday and Friday. So they would have to buzz it a little bit and hair and makeup. But listen, guys, I have worked with men who have to shave twice a day when they're shooting because our shoot days are so long. If they have a clean shave and look, by four o'clock, they get a little bit of a shadow and they send them back in to wash their face and shave with a razor so that we can keep shooting into the night and they match.
假期。所以我们周一到周五拍戏，雷恩只有周末的时间来长出这些胡茬。这是他真正的面部毛发。不过，困难的地方在于一整周每天都要保持一致。所以在周一，他带着胡茬来拍戏，但在周二、周三、周四和周五，他们必须保持完全相同的长度。所以他们得在发型和化妆间稍微用推剪修剪一下。但听着，伙计们，我曾和男演员合作过，他们在拍戏时每天必须刮两次胡子，因为我们的拍摄时间太长了。如果他们刮得光溜溜的，看吧，到四点钟，他们就会长出一小片阴影，然后他们会被送回化妆间洗脸，用剃须刀再刮一遍，这样我们才能继续拍夜戏，并且保持连戏。
Oh, can you imagine if you had to shave your legs like halfway through the day? No. I'd be so bummed. Yeah. That's a lot of maintenance. It's a lot of maintenance. Those guys would come in the hair and makeup trailers in the morning and they would, first thing they would do is shave. They wouldn't even shave at home a lot of them because they wanted it to last as long as possible for the shoot day. Well, then there's also the fellows that have a hard time growing a beard. My husband's one of those guys. Yeah. And then I've seen in there where they have to put hair on their face if their character needs a beard. Yeah, they get fakey hair. Fakey hair. Well, moving on, back in the episode, Pam has this talking head where she's
哦，你能想象如果你在一天中间还得刮腿毛吗？不。我会沮丧死的。是的。那要花费很多维护工作。需要很多维护。那些家伙早上来到发型和化妆车里，他们要做的第一件事就是刮胡子。他们中的很多人甚至不在家里刮胡子，因为他们想让它在拍摄日维持尽可能长的时间。好吧，然后还有那些很难留出胡子的伙计们。我丈夫就是那种人。是的。然后我见过他们在那里如果角色需要胡子的话，必须把假发贴在脸上。对，他们用假发。假发。好吧，继续，回到这一集中，帕姆有一个访谈，她要
going to explain this tension between Dwight and Angela. She says Dwight Mercy killed Angela's cat and it's caused a lot of unpleasantness. Angela has been in this real foul mood. She has. He put her cat in the freezer. I'm not blaming her. I would be in a foul mood. I, by the way, this is setting up the runner between you and Phyllis in this episode. That is one of my favorite of all time. You know what I noticed in this talking head is that Pam has on that unicorn necklace again. Oh, she switched from her butterfly to the unicorn. She's a unicorn again and Angela has a gold cat necklace. I noticed that and it's real cute. I know. I would wear it. I would wear it. Well, back in the bullpen, Stanley is dancing to the music on his new website and Phyllis is so
解释德怀特和安吉拉之间的这种紧张关系。她说德怀特慈悲杀死了安吉拉的猫，这引起了许多不愉快。安吉拉的心情一直非常糟糕。确实如此。他把她的猫放进冰箱里了。我不怪她。我的心情也会很糟糕。顺便说一句，这为你在这一集中和菲利斯之间的对手戏做了铺垫。那是我有史以来最喜欢的对手戏之一。你知道我在这个访谈中注意到什么吗？帕姆又戴上了那个独角兽项链。哦，她从蝴蝶项链换成了独角兽项链。她又戴上独角兽了，而安吉拉戴着一个金猫项链。我注意到了，真的超级可爱。我知道。我会戴的。我会戴的。好吧，回到办公区，斯坦利随着他新网站上的音乐跳舞，菲利斯觉得
tickled. And it's just a small moment, but these are the moments I absolutely love about our show. Yeah. Just these little glimpses into the different desk pods. I just love it. Well, then we go to corporate Ang and we have a Ryan talking head. He is in this gorgeous corner office in a skyscraper, feet up on the desk. And you know what? He wants you to know, yeah, he created a website. Yeah. He created it. No big whoop. No big whoop. He's not trying to reinvent the wheel, but he's taken it to the streets while keeping an eye on the streets, Wall Street. You know, paper buying just became fun. Yeah, boom. But then you hear a voice of someone who's like, I told you not to do these interviews in my office. So first of all, it's like,
好玩极了。这只是一个小瞬间，但这些正是我绝对喜欢我们剧集的时刻。是的。只是这些对不同办公桌区域的惊鸿一瞥。我太喜欢了。好吧，然后我们去到总公司，安吉拉，我们有一个瑞安的访谈。他在摩天大楼里一间华丽的转角办公室里，双脚翘在办公桌上。你知道吗？他想让你知道，是的，他创建了一个网站。是的。他创建的。没什么大不了的。没什么大不了的。他并不是想重新发明轮子，但他把它带到了街头，同时密切关注着华尔街。你知道，买纸变得有趣了。是的，轰。但接着你听到一个人的声音说，我告诉过你不要在我的办公室里做这些采访。所以首先，这就像是，
how many of these has he tried to do in this guy's office? It's not his office. Ryan is such like, oh my God, he's such a cheese ball. Well, and then the camera pans down and you see a name plate on the desk that says Thomas Dean. And we got a fan question about this for Miles Peterson. Does the name Thomas Dean have any significance? Yes, guys. Tom Dean was our PA and that name plate was in Tom's honor. Okay, Jenna, I think the voice of Thomas Dean is our editor, Dean Holland. I think it is too. Right? Yes. I would have sworn he was in the room with me when I heard that. It's gotta be him. Yeah. I think you're right. Well, I want to take us now to the scene with Andy and Dwight. I love that Dwight has his little champion that Andy is so rooting for
他在这家伙办公室试过多少次了？这不是他的办公室。瑞恩真是个，天哪，他太虚伪了。然后镜头往下摇，你看到桌上有个名牌，上面写着托马斯·迪恩。我们为此收到了一个粉丝提问，是给迈尔斯·彼得森的。托马斯·迪恩这个名字有什么特殊含义吗？是的，伙计们。汤姆·迪恩是我们的制片助理，那个名牌是为了纪念汤姆而做的。好吧，珍娜，我觉得托马斯·迪恩的声音是我们的剪辑师迪恩·霍兰德。我也觉得是。对吧？是的。我敢发誓我听到那个声音时，他就和我共处一室。肯定是他。对。我觉得你说得对。好吧，现在我想带大家看看安迪和德怀特的对手戏。我太喜欢德怀特有安迪这个小啦啦队队员全力支持他了
him in this. He's gotten really into it. And he says to Dwight, you know what, you need like a noise or something for like when you make a good sale, right? Yeah. He's got his dry erase board, it's dried against the computer. And now they're brainstorming what's the noise that goes off whenever Dwight makes a sale, right? We think we need a noise. Yeah. Here's Andy's suggestion. He could say kudos. Job well done. A chime, a bell. And Jim is peppering in these little smartass comments. He's saying, how about Zippity-Doodle, a gong. And Dwight's like, ignore him. Here's what we're going to do. Here are the keys to my car. Go out under a whole bunch of pelts. Amazing. There's a bear horn. Get that. And he does. Yeah, he does. Andy is going to blow
在这件事上。他真的完全投入进去了。他对德怀特说，你知道吗，你得弄个声音什么的，比如当你做成一笔好生意的时候，对吧？对。他拿着白板，靠在电脑上。现在他们正在集思广益，想一个每当德怀特做成生意时就会响起的音效，对吧？我们觉得需要一个音效。对。这是安迪的建议。他可以说“干得好”。工作干得漂亮。一阵风铃声、一个铃铛。而吉姆则不断插进这些自作聪明的评论。他说，来个“哔哔嘟嘟”、一面锣怎么样。德怀特就说，别理他。我们要这么做。这是我车钥匙。出去在一堆兽皮下面。太棒了。有个气喇叭。去拿那个。他照做了。对，他照做了。安迪要吹
a bear horn every time Dwight makes a sale. Well, now we go to a scene that I've been waiting for. Angela and Phyllis, they're unrolling a banner for the launch party. But Phyllis has printed a banner that says lunch party. Angela is furious. She is so pissed off. She actually looks at Phyllis and says, what is wrong with you? Oh, Angela is in rear form. She's in rear form. And there was a deleted scene that might give us a window. Okay. About this. First of all, we know the breakup, right? She's still mad about sprinkles. She's ticked off. Well, there's another layer to it. There's a talking head where she says, tonight my party will be broadcast out to five other states, which means it will be compared to Denise
德怀特每做成一笔生意，就吹一次气喇叭。好吧，现在我们来到我一直期待的一场戏。安拉和菲利斯，她们正在为发布会拉开一条横幅。但菲利斯打印的横幅上写着“午餐派对”。安吉拉气疯了。她火冒三丈。她居然看着菲利斯说，你脑子有毛病吧？哦，安吉拉状态神勇。她状态太神勇了。还有一个被删减的片段或许能让我们一探究竟。好吧。关于这件事。首先，我们知道他们分手了，对吧？她还在为小不点生气。她气不打一处来。好吧，这还有另一层原因。有一个面对镜头的独白，她说，今晚我的派对将向其他五个州直播，这意味着它将与丹尼斯
Stem's party in Buffalo. Oh, my God. There is a party planning committee rival. Denise Stem's in Buffalo? Yeah. And Angela hates her. And they get their parties compared. What is the backstory between Angela and Denise? Oh, it goes on from there. She throws major shade at her. She's like, Denise, you know what? We can all defrost hors d'oeuvres in a microwave. All right. That's what she does every party. And also Denise, you're not fooling anyone with those curls. We know you get a perm. Okay. Like it goes. Oh, my God. Denise Stem's. So she's got her breakup. She has our cat in the freezer. Phyllis cannot handle one simple task and her party will be compared to Denise Stem's. So Angela is not
斯特姆在布法罗的派对进行比较。哦，天哪。派对策划委员会竟然有对手了。布法罗的丹尼斯·斯特姆？对。而且安吉拉恨死她了。她们的派对会被拿来比较。安吉拉和丹尼斯之间有什么背景故事吗？哦，不止呢。她对对方进行了狠狠的贬低。她说，丹尼斯，你知道吗？我们谁都会用微波炉解冻开胃菜。好吧。她每个派对都这么干。而且还有丹尼斯，你顶着那些卷发可骗不了任何人。我们都知道你烫过头。好吧。简直没完没了。哦，天哪。丹尼斯·斯特姆。所以她刚失恋。她把我们的猫冻在冰箱里。菲利斯连这么一件简单的事都搞不定，而她的派对还要跟丹尼斯·斯特姆的作比较。所以安吉拉根本
having it. The stakes are high for Angela. Yeah. Well, this cuts to a Phyllis talking head where she explains that basically she's going to keep her cool and she is going to try out some new tactics for dealing with Angela. She has printed out all of this advice on how to deal with difficult people. She actually says she googled how to deal with difficult people. Well, you know what, Ang? What? Obviously, I had to Google how to deal with difficult people. I wondered if you would, would you find out? Well, what I found out is that a lot of the tactics that Phyllis uses in this episode are the advice for dealing with difficult people, asking the difficult person how they're feeling, like saying affirmative things like I could see why you might be upset,
无法接受。安吉拉这回压力山大。对。好吧，镜头切到菲利斯的一个独白镜头，她解释说基本上她要保持冷静，并且她打算尝试一些应对安吉拉的新策略。她打印了所有关于如何与难缠的人打交道的建议。她甚至说她在谷歌上搜索了如何与难缠的人打交道。好吧，你知道吗，安吉？什么？很显然，我不得不在谷歌上搜索怎么跟难缠的人打交道。我想知道你会不会，你会不会发现？好吧，我发现的是，菲利斯在这集里用的很多策略，都是应对难缠之人的建议，比如问那个难缠的人感觉如何，比如多说一些肯定的的话，比如我能理解你为什么会生
like things like that. Well, I'll tell you something. If someone had made a banner that said lunch party and then turned to me and said, how do you feel about the fact that the banner says lunch? I would probably say, I feel like you're a dumbass. That's how I feel. Like that is not something you say to someone who's already annoyed with you. So that cracked me up when Phyllis said that. I was like, if I was Angela, I would still be pissed off. That would not have helped my situation. And you know, it's not helping Phyllis that Kevin is now involved in this discussion. And then Michael walks up and says, nobody cares about this party anyway, booster seat, shorty joke number two, shorty joke number two. And I want
气，诸如此类的话。好吧，我告诉你一件事。如果有人做了个写着“午餐派对”的横幅，然后转身对我说，“对于横幅上写着‘午餐’这件事你有什么感想？”我可能会说，“我觉得你是个大笨蛋。”我就是这么想的。这根本不是对一个本来就已经在生所以菲利斯说完这话时我差点笑死。我想，如果我是安吉拉，我还是会火冒三丈。这根本对我的处境毫无帮助。而且你知道的，凯文现在也卷入了这场讨论，这对菲利斯毫无帮助。接着迈尔斯走过来，说，反正也没人在乎这个派对，增高垫，矮子笑话之二，矮子笑话之二。我想
you to know that Steve improvised a whole bunch and I never knew what he was going to say. And there's bloopers of me cracking up. But there you go. Angela's ticked and no one is helping. Well, this is when Angela has her talking head that I love so much when she says that she's been asked to plan a party with only a $65 budget and four idiots that are doing nothing but weighing her down. Oh, and her cat is still dead. Yeah. And the entire world will see it, including Denise Stims. Yeah. Well, listen, I think we should take a break because when we come back Dwight is going to fuel up for his big competition against the computer. He's got to. He's got to refuel. Yeah, big day. All right, we'll see you in a sec.
让你们知道的是，史蒂夫即兴发挥了非常多的内容，我永远不知道他会说出什么。里面有我笑场的花絮。但就是这样。安吉拉气炸了，而没有人能帮上忙。好吧，这就是安吉拉那个我超爱的独白时刻，她说她被要求只用65美元的预算和一个四个笨蛋来策划一个派对，而这些人除了拖她后腿什么也没做。哦，她的猫还死了。对。而且全世界都会看到，包括丹尼斯·斯特姆。对。好吧，听着，我觉得我们该休息一下，因为等我们回来时，德怀特要为他与电脑的大战补充能量了。他必须这么做。他得补充能量。对，重要的一天。好吧，我们一会儿见。
All right, we are back. And like we said, Dwight is fueling up literally. He's squeezing some kind of power protein gunk in his mouth. Yeah, it's a power gel. Of course I had to look it up, Jenna. Oh, it's called power gel? Well, their power gels are energy gels, right? Yeah. And I looked them up. Here's what they are. They're like a liquid carbohydrate and they're used by endurance athletes to fuel their training. Like when you see guys running marathons or, you know, the triathletes or these people who do the whole like tour de France, you know? Yeah. And they're squeezing these little tubes of things in their mouth. That's what this is. But it's for high endurance athletes to like replenish everything that's been depleted from the running and cycling.
好，我们回来了。就像我们说的，德怀特正在字面意义上补充能量。他正把某种能量蛋白质黏糊物往嘴里挤。对，那是能量胶。我当然得查查它是什么，珍娜。哦，它叫能量胶？好吧，他们说的能量胶就是能量啫喱，对吧？对。我查了一下。它们是这样的：它们类似于液态碳水化合物，被耐力运动员用来为训练补充能量。就像你看到那些跑马拉松的人，你知道的，铁人三项运动员，或者那些参加环法自行车赛的人，你知道吧？对。他们把这些一小管一小管的东西往嘴里挤。就是这个。但它是为高耐力运动员准备的，用来补充跑步和骑行所消耗的体力。
Jenna, there's so much online about these. Oh my gosh. There are multiple YouTube videos about how to eat one, when to eat them. Are you supposed to eat them before doing the endurance activity while doing it or after? While doing it. Like when you get depleted, you know? Okay. And talk about your random history in your search engine. Yeah. Jenna, I was watching a video of these two guys cycling in England. We're talking about their energy gels. I'm like, what am I doing watching these two guys in England? Oh my God. Also, there's a ton, a ton of like options for you. If you want energy gels, and I found one that I really feel like Dwight inspired. What is it? It's called beat elite. No. Yes. Beat elite energy gel. You know,
珍娜，网上关于这些东西的信息太多了。哦，天哪。有好几个关于如何吃这个、什么时候吃的YouTube视频。你是应该在做耐力运动前吃、进行中吃还是之后吃？进行中吃。就像当你体力耗尽的时候，你知道的？好吧。说到你搜索引擎里的随机历史记录。呀，珍娜，我当时在看两个英国人骑自行车的视频。我们正在讨论他们的能量胶。我想，我到底在干什么，为什么要看这两个英国人在英国骑车？哦，天哪。另外，如果你想要能量胶，里面有成吨成吨的选择，我发现了一种我觉得绝对是受德怀特启发的。是什么？它叫Beat Elite。不是吧。没错。Beat Elite能量胶。你知道吗，
this is what Michael needed during Fun Run. Yes. Not Fettuccine Alfredo. No. He needed a beat elite. Well, Dwight is being very annoying. He's annoying Jim. He throws his gel packet onto Jim's desk. Jim has to get rid of it. So Jim goes up to Pam and says, do you want to pull a prank on Dwight because he's being super annoying? And Pam is, she's torn. She's like, well, I mean, he's going through a breakup. But then the bear horn. Yeah. So then Dwight like fires off the bear horn. It's really loud. And Pam's like, you know what? I'm in. What are we doing? So Jim hatches this plan where they are going to direct message Dwight as the computer system. They're going to send him messages as if the computer has come alive. Yes. And you know, this is perfect for Dwight.
这就是迈尔斯在慈善长跑时需要的。没错。而不是什么意大利宽面。不。他需要Beat Elite。好吧，德怀特太烦人了。他烦到了吉姆。他把他的能量胶包装袋扔到了吉姆的桌上。吉姆不得不把它处理掉。于是吉姆走到帕姆身边说，你想整蛊一下德怀特吗，因为他太烦人了？而帕姆呢，她有点纠结。她说，嗯，我是说，他正经历失恋呢。但接着气喇叭响了。对。于是德怀特就像那样按响了气喇叭。声音真的很大。帕姆就说，你知道吗？算我一个。我们怎么整？于是吉姆想出了一个计划，他们要以电脑系统的名义直接给德怀特发私信。他们要以电脑复活的口吻给他发信息。没错。你知道的，这太适合德怀特了。
Yeah. This is the perfect prank because of course Dwight would entertain this. So when Pam is typing to Dwight, these DMs, we had some fan questions from Amanda McKnight and Matthew Lister. When Pam's typing all of the instant messages, was it Jenna typing with her crazy good typing skills or was it the computer? Well, I'll tell you, it was both. So when they do these scenes where something specific has to show up on the computer screen, they've created a program where it doesn't matter what button you press on the keyboard, the words come up as they should. So you can't mess it up. It's kind of fun. It's actually, yeah. Yeah. You can hit any key. You could hit the space bar five times the sentence will type. Yes. And at the end of the
对。这是最完美的整蛊，因为德怀特肯定会当真。所以当帕姆给德怀特打字、发送这些私信时，我们收到了来自阿曼达·麦克奈特和马修·利斯特的粉丝提问。当帕姆打出所有即时消息时，真的是珍娜用她超强的打字技巧在打字吗，还是电脑生成的？好吧，我告诉你，两者都有。所以当他们拍摄这些需要在电脑屏幕上显示特定内容的戏时，他们创造了一个程序，无论你在键盘上按哪个键，文字都会按预期显示出来。所以你不会出错。这挺有意思的。其实是这样的，对。对。你可以敲击任意键。你可以按五次空格键，句子就会被打出来。是的。在那个场景的
scene, you hit escape and then you would usually hit like F1 and then it starts the program over again. So they're super fun to play with. It sort of takes you back to your childhood when you would want to pretend like you were doing something. I always love these little programs. But at the same time, I was personally compelled to type out the words correctly. But this caused a problem because it was too many strokes of the keyboard because each time I hit a key, it translated into more than one letter, right? So it would be like in order to run this program, I would have to type 24 things, but to actually type the sentence, it would be more like 48. So I had to like really hold back. It was it was tough for me. I know. I know it was. Yeah. Because
最后，你按下Esc键，然后通常按一下F1键，程序就会重新启动。所以玩起来超级有趣。这有点像把你带回童年，那时你总是想假装自己在做某事。我一直很喜欢这些小程序。但与此同时，我个人又忍不住想把字正确地打出来。但这导致了一个问题，那就是按键次数太多了，因为我每按一次键，它就会转化为不止一个字母，对吧？所以就变成为了运行这个程序，我必须敲击24次，但实际上要打出这个句子，更接近48次。所以我必须拼命克制。这对我来说挺难的。我知道。我知道确实很难。对。因为
your integrity as a typist, you're like, that's not correct. That is not how many keys you hit to spell the word. Hello. That's right. And I made my living as a transcriber for many years. I know. So I need to type what I hear. It was real hard. Well, you did it. I did it. I got through it. You got through it. But it's a really cute runner for Jim and Pam and it's making Dwight crazy. Well, he says in his talking head, sometimes computers come to life, but he is not scared. It is the computer that should be scared because he has been salesman 13 months out of the last 12 months. You heard him correctly. In February, instead of a raise, Dunder Mifflin awarded him two plaques. I really feel like Dunder Mifflin has overlooked Dwight. I agree. I mean, he is clearly the best
作为一个打字员的职业操守，你会想，这不对啊。拼写“Hello”这个词根本不用敲这么多下键。没错。而且我多年来一直以速记员为生。我懂。所以我得听到什么就打什么。这真的很难。不过你做到了。我做到了。我挺过来了。你挺过来了。但这对于吉姆和帕姆来说是个非常可爱的连续笑点，而且把德怀特气得够呛。好吧，他在独白里说，有时候电脑会复活，但他并不害怕。该害怕的是电脑才对，因为在过去的12个月里，他有13个月都是销售冠军。你没听错。在二月份，邓德米夫林没有给他加薪，而是颁发给他两块奖牌。我真的觉得邓德米夫林一直忽视了德怀特。我同意。我是说，他显然是最好的
salesman and has been for a long time and he never gets upper management and this is going to go on for years for him. Now, listen, he's salty. He's a salty character, but I feel like Dunder Mifflin could do better by Dwight. There, I'll just, I said it. I'm glad you said it. Thank you. It needed to be said. Michael is now really needing the ladies in Oscar to weigh in on his outfit for the fancy party he's going to go to. This shirt is ridiculous. Ridiculous. It's bright purple. It has like a sheen to it. Yeah. Like light, light bounces off of it. And it is so, so tight. And Oscar has a great line. Oscar says, is this why I'm in here? And he just gets up and walks out. I know. And no one likes it. And all the women are like, no, no, no. Also, Jenna, did you notice
销售员，而且当之无愧很多年了，但他从来没进过高管层，而且这种状态对他来说还要持续好几年。听着，他这人有点怨气。他是个满腹牢骚的角色，但我觉得邓德米夫林对德怀特本可以做得更好。话就放这儿了，我说出来了。我很高兴你这么说。谢谢。这话早就该说了。迈尔斯现在非常需要女士们和奥斯卡对他的高级派对行头给出意见。这件衬衫太荒谬了。荒谬透顶。它是亮紫色的。带有一种光泽感。对。就像光线，光线打在上面会反光。而且它真的超级无敌紧。奥斯卡有一句绝妙的台词。奥斯卡说，我来这儿就是为了看这个吗？然后他直接起身走人了。我知道。而且没人喜欢它。所有的女士都说，不，不，不。还有，珍娜，你注意到
how long it is? Very long. He insists that it's European cut, which is the same thing he said about the woman's suit that he bought. Michael is very attracted to this idea of a European cut. He thinks that this is style. Yes. It could also be what you say when something doesn't fit you right. Like the next time I put on a pair of sweatpants that are like too long in the crotch or something, I'm going to say, oh, it's European cut. European cut. Well, then Jan calls in the conference room. And it's clear that Michael is unsure about taking this call, but he does take the call. Yeah, he does not want to talk to her. And he takes the call. She does not want to go to the party. She doesn't want to go. But why all her friends will be there. She's like, Michael, I
它有多长了吗？非常长。他坚称这是欧版剪裁，这跟他评价他买的那套女式西装时说的话一模一样。迈尔斯对欧版剪裁这个概念非常着迷。他认为这就是时尚。对。这也可能是当你衣服不合身时的借口。就像下次我穿上一条裆部太长之类的运动裤时，我会说，哦，这是欧版剪裁。欧版剪裁。然后珍很打来电话。显然迈尔斯很不确定要不要接这个电话，但他还是接了。对，他根本不想跟她说话。但他还是接了。她不想去派对。她不想去。但为什么她所有的朋友都会在那里。她说，迈尔斯，我
was fired. Yeah, she's like, they're not my friends. So Michael asks if he could bring Carol instead. She's like, what? And he's like, fine, I'll find someone I didn't sleep with. Yeah. But he doesn't want to go alone. That's the point. Well, there is a deleted scene. Michael and Jan go on to have even more conversation. And Jenna, it's all delicious. It is all amazing. If I could, I would have like asked them to leave it all in. I am telling you. She says, you know what I want to do? I want to make a pot roast. Why don't we stay home? I'll make a pot roast. Oh, do you know what I did today? I went to Costco. I got some more zen. Oh, and I bought a bike. And guess how much the bike was. And he's like, I don't know, $60. She goes, why would you say a bicycle was
被解雇了。对，她说，他们才不是我的朋友。所以迈尔斯问他能不能带卡罗尔去。她一脸震惊，说，什么？而他说，好吧，那我找个没睡过的人去。对。但他又不想一个人去。重点就在这儿。好吧，有一个被删减的片段。迈尔斯和珍进行了更多的对话，珍娜，这段对话简直妙不可言。简直太棒了。如果可以的话，我真想求他们全留下来。我跟你讲。她说，你知道我想做什么吗？我想做一份炖牛肉。我们为什么不呆在家里？我来做炖牛肉。哦，你知道我今天干了什么吗？我去好市多（Costco）了。我买了一些禅意。哦，我还买了一辆自行车。你猜这辆自行车多少钱。而他说，我不知道，60美元吧。她接着说，迈尔斯，你怎么会觉得一辆自行车才
$60, Michael? Why would you say that? And he's like, I don't know. And she goes, it was $500, Michael. Oh my God. It's just more of a window into their relationship. And I can't get enough of it. I can't get enough either. It's all so good. She bought a bike at Costco for 500 bucks. What is she doing all day? Wait, did she buy the bike at Costco or she went to Costco? She bought the bike at Costco. Oh, I see. Well, listen, the competition is on between Dwight and the website. Dwight is not doing well. But in the meantime, Pam and Jim, they're in the break room, the flirt room. They're having a snack, 12 minutes, two seconds, baby carrot alert. John Krasinski is eating those baby carrots again. Oh, he's back on his healthy kick. Well, yeah, he's no more popcorn. He's back to
60美元呢？迈尔斯，你怎么会这么想？而他说，我不知道。她说，那是500美元，迈尔斯。哦，天哪。这让我们对他们的关系有了更深入的了解。我真是看不够。我也看不够。实在太精彩了。她在好市多花500块钱买了一辆自行车。她整天都在干嘛？等等，她是去好市多买的自行车，还是她顺便去了好市多？她是在好市多买的自行车。哦，原来如此。好吧，听着，德怀特和网站之间的竞争正在进行中。德怀特情况不妙。但与此同时，帕姆和吉姆，他们正在休息室，也就是调情室。他们正在吃零食，12分钟2秒，小胡萝卜警报。约翰·卡拉辛斯基又在吃那些小胡萝卜了。哦，他又开始追求健康了。好吧，对，不吃爆米花啦。他又开始吃
the carrots. Michael walks in and says, Hey, what are you guys doing tonight? Because I've got two tickets to the party in New York. You want to go? And they're like, you know what, why not? They're like, let's go to New York together. Let's do it. But then he says, all right, great, but you're gonna have to duke it out. Just let me know who wins. And that's when Pam realizes, Oh, one of the tickets is for Michael. And then she says, as soon as he leaves the room, not it. Smart. Yeah, smart. So Jim is going to go to this fancy sushi New York launch party with Michael. I bet he's so excited. Now Dwight is on the phone and he's yelling at a client for ordering through the website rather than through him. And Jim and the computer both insist that Dwight seems worried, right? Yep.
胡萝卜了。迈尔斯走进来问，嘿，你们俩今晚干嘛呢？因为我有两张去纽约派对的票。你们想去吗？他们就说，你知道吗，为什么不呢？他们说，一起去纽约吧。走吧。但接着他说，好吧，太棒了，不过你们得争夺一下。谁赢了告诉我一声。就在那时帕姆意识到，哦，其中一张票是给迈尔斯的。然后她在他一离开房间立刻就说，我不去。聪明。对，很聪明。所以吉姆要和迈尔斯一起去那个高级寿司纽约发布会派对。我打赌他兴奋极了。现在德怀特正在打电话，他冲着一个客户大吼大叫，因为对方是通过网站而不是通过他来下单。而吉姆和电脑都坚称德怀特看起来很担心，对吧？没错。
It's like the computer is like heckling Dwight. He's kind of trolling him. And Dwight writes a very long message at 1301 in binary. And I looked it up on the internet. I looked it up as well. Oh, okay. What did you find? Well, Pam says that Dwight said, why don't you 0111111011011. Yeah. I ended up on Reddit. So did I. Well, oh boy. Yeah. And someone said that in the way that Pam reads it, it means nothing. Right. But if you add back the zeros that I guess would normally be there in binary code, that it spells F O, like yes, F off. Why don't you F off? Is did you read the same thing? I read the same thing. There was a lot about the two ASCII codes in binary. It was like a little detailed. But according to that Reddit thread
就像电脑在挑衅德怀特一样。它有点在网上恶搞他。而德怀特在13分01秒时用二进制写了一条非常长的信息。我在网上查了查。我也查了。哦，好吧。你查到什么了？好吧，帕姆说德怀特写的是，你为什么不0111111011011。对。我最后刷到了红迪网（Reddit）。我也是。哦，天哪。对。有人说，按照帕姆读出来的方式，这毫无意义。对吧。但如果你把二进制代码里我猜原本应该在那里的零加回去，它拼出来的是“F O”，就像是“滚”。你为什么不滚开？你读到的是这个吗？我也读到一样的东西。里面有很多关于二进制中两个ASCII码的讨论。有点详细。但根据那个我们俩大概都读过的红迪网帖子——
that I think we both read, hi, hi Reddit thread folks. Dwight's telling the computer to F off. There you go. Well, now Angela is very angry about some spoons. This is one of my favorite scenes I ever did with Phyllis for the whole run of the show. So I was texting with Jen. I was like, Jen, I love the scene so much. And she said it was one of her favorite things to write this whole exchange. And I want you to know we could not stop laughing. Well, I know that Angela, because you can't see me, but I sat at reception the entire time you were filming this scene. Yes. And we were cracking up. It was so funny. And it's in the bloopers. And at one point I was finally holding it together. And then Jen
红迪网的朋友们你们好——德怀特是在让电脑滚蛋。就是这样。好吧，现在安吉拉因为一些勺子而大发雷霆。这是我和菲利斯在整部剧里拍过的我最喜欢的场景之一。所以我当时给珍发短信说，珍，我太喜欢这个场景了。她说这是她写整段对话时最喜欢的部分之一。我想让你们知道，我们当时根本笑得停不下来。好吧，我知道安吉拉，因为你看不到我，但我拍这场戏时一直坐在前台那里。对。我们当时笑得前仰后合。太搞笑了。而且这都被剪进花絮里了。有一次我好不容易快憋住了，然后
Solada, who's sitting on the sofa by reception starts laughing. Yeah. And I was like, Jen. And so if you watch the bloopers, you will hear Jen laughing. I'll tell you the line that got you guys every time. I remember it so clearly. It was when Phyllis says the word tone. She couldn't get through that word. She couldn't say tone. She couldn't say tone without laughing. And then I started anticipating her little mouth saying tune. And then I couldn't keep it together. Sam, will you play this scene? It's at 13 minutes, 32 seconds. I asked for assorted cutlery and I got back spoons. These are worthless. I want to understand what you're saying, but it's difficult for me when you use that tone. Phyllis, these are spoons. Spoons
坐在前台旁边沙发上的珍·索拉达开始笑了。对。然后我就想，珍。所以如果你看花絮，你会听到珍的笑声。我告诉你每次都能把你们逗笑的那句台词。我记得太清楚了。就是当菲利斯说“语气”（tone）这个词时。她怎么都念不好这个词。她就是说不出“tone”。她不笑场根本说不出“tone”。然后我开始预判她那小嘴说成“tune”（音调）的样子。接着我也憋不住了。山姆，能放一下这个场景吗？在13分32秒。我要求提供配套餐具，结果送来一堆勺子。这些毫无价值。我想理解你在说什么，但当你用这种语气说话时，我很难理解。菲利斯，这些是勺子。勺子
have rounded tops and are used to scoop things. What we need are forks, which have prongs or tiny spears on top. And we need knives, which have blades. Do you understand me now? I have to say you can't see it when you listen to that clip. But one of my favorite moments is the hand gesture you make when you say blades. You do this little scoffy thing with your hand. You're like blades. We did a few takes and in one take I did forks like this. Like I did like prongs with my fingers. But that looked too weird. So then I thought I'll only do one hand gesture and I'll save it for the knife. So good. And my cheerleaders out there, you know that you know blades, blades, candlesticks. Come on. Wait, that's actually a hand gesture in cheerleading for a blade?
顶部是圆的，是用来舀东西的。我们需要的是叉子，上面有尖齿或小刺。我们还需要刀子，上面有刀刃。你现在听懂了吗？我得说，当你听这段音频时你是看不到的。但我最喜欢的时刻之一就是你说“刀刃”时做的那个手势。你用手做了一个非常不屑的动作。你就像是“刀刃”一样。我们拍了好几次，其中有一次我做叉子是这样的。就像我用手指比划了叉尖。但那看起来太诡异了。于是我想我还是只做一个手势好了，留给刀子用。太棒了。我的啦啦队女孩们，你们一定知道刀刃、烛台动作。得了吧。等等，啦啦队里“刀刃”真的是一个手势吗？
That's blade. Okay. Yeah, candlesticks. Candlestick is a fist. Why did these need special names? I don't know. I don't know. It was cheerleading camp and who even knows if it's universal? Maybe it was just my cheerleading camp. Are there any more? I'm dying to know. Well, you know jazz hands. Jazz hands I get. That's a whole thing. I mean, you have to like put all your fingers out and kind of like flutter your hands. I mean, that makes sense to me. And then this is candlesticks. Candlesticks is fists. And then blades. Blades is just your palms. Yeah, like what I did in the scene. Yeah. All right. Okay. So like when you're doing cheerleading camp and you're choreographing your cheer here, in your head, are you thinking like blade, blade, jazz hands, candlesticks, blade, blade?
那就是刀刃。好吧。对，烛台动作。烛台动作就是一个拳头。为什么这些非得起特有的名字？我不知道。我不知道。那是啦啦队夏令营里的，谁知道它是不是通用的呢？也许只是我们啦啦队夏令营那样。还有别的吗？我太想知道了。好吧，你知道爵士手（jazz hands）吧。爵士手我懂。那是全套动作。我的意思是，你得把所有的手指都伸开，然后像这样让手掌颤抖。我是说，这对我来说挺好理解的。然后这是烛台动作。烛台动作就是握拳。接着是刀刃。刀刃就是把手掌并拢。对，就像我在剧里做的那样。好吧。好吧。所以当你在啦啦队夏令营里编排啦啦队口号时，在你的脑海里，你会想：刀刃、刀刃、爵士手、烛台动作、刀刃、刀刃吗？
Yes. And you're like ready. Okay. Blade. Candlestick. Candlestick. Okay. Blade. Got it. We're doing this and no one can see us. No one can see us, but I am enjoying it immensely. Okay. No, okay. This is another thing Angela did in high school. Everyone also a cheerleader. In addition to all of the musical instruments and sports that she played. Well, I was the mascot for football. And the mascot. I was the mascot for football and then I cheered. I cheered for basketball. No, but I told you my mom's theory is keep them busy. They stay out of trouble. Yeah. And also nothing good happens after midnight. Nothing good happens after midnight. Well, listen, Darrell is about to deliver some paper to Kelly. And there's some flirty flirt
是的。然后你会想“准备”。好吧。刀刃。烛台动作。烛台动作。好吧。刀刃。懂了。我们在做这个动作，而且没人能看见我们。没人能看见我们，但我乐在其中。好吧。不，好吧。这是安吉拉高中时做过的另一件事。每个人也都当过啦啦队。除了她玩过的所有乐器和运动项目之外。好吧，我是橄榄球队的吉祥物。还是吉祥物。我是橄榄球队的吉祥物，然后我还跳啦啦队。我为篮球队跳啦啦队。不，但正如我告诉你的，我妈妈的理论是：让他们忙起来。他们就不会惹麻烦了。对。而且午夜过后没发生过什么好事。午夜过后没发生过什么好事。好吧，听着，达瑞尔正准备给凯利送一些纸。内勤办公室里发生了一场调情。
that happens in that annex. Well Dwight is so furious that Kelly ordered off the website. He's like, do you know what this means? And he's yelling at her and Darrell's like, step off. Well, listen, she explains it's really cute. You take the paper and you put it in a little shopping basket and it makes a cute little sound. This is all Kelly could ever hope for. Yeah. Yeah. Online shopping. Like she has arrived. But Darrell comes to her defense, like you said. And suddenly she's not missing Ryan so much, is she? There's a little moment here. Yeah. So now we're going to move into some sabotage. Did you say sandwich? Dwight gets out this little red box. He unlocks a lot of things and then he unlocks this little box
德怀特因为凯利在网站上订购纸张而气急败坏。他就像是，你知道这意味着什么吗？他冲着她大吼大叫，而达瑞尔就说，离远点。好吧，听着，她解释说这真的超可爱。你把纸放进一个小购物篮里，它会发出一个可爱的小声音。这就是凯利梦寐以求的一切。对。对。网上购物。就像她终于熬出头了。但就像你说的，达瑞尔站出来维护她了。突然之间，她没那么想念瑞恩了吧？这里有一个小插曲。对。所以现在我们要转到一些破坏行动上。你刚才说三明治？德怀特拿出了那个红色的带锁小盒子。他解开了很多锁，然后打开了这个小盒子
and he explains that when he left staples, he took some of the staples leads as a souvenir. He doesn't know why he did it, but maybe it was to use them one day and he's going to use them today. Yeah. He has got to beat the computer. In his mind, if he beats the computer, he wins Angela back. I think that's where his rationale is. Yes, exactly. And it's working. Yeah. He calls up and they're like, how did you get this number? And he's like, it's not important, but do you want to save money on paper? And they clearly say yes, because he starts logging all of these sales and it's a very big deal. It's a big, big deal. And while this is happening, Michael and Jim are getting ready to leave for the party.
并解释说，当他离开史泰博（Staples）时，他顺走了他们的一些销售线索作为纪念品。他不知道自己为什么要这么做，但也许是为了有一天能用上，而他今天就要用它们了。对。他必须打败电脑。在他心里，如果他打败了电脑，他就能把安吉拉赢回来。我觉得这就是他的逻辑所在。是的，完全如此。而且奏效了。对。他打电话过去，对方就问，你怎么弄到这个号的？而他说，这不重要，但你想在纸张上省钱吗？他们显然说想，因为他开始记录下所有这些销售额，这是一件非常了不起的大事。这是一件天大的事。与此同时，迈尔斯和吉姆正准备动身去派对。
Michael sort of does this sing-songy and tells everyone that he'll be back tomorrow, you know, the way he does his little sing-talky thing. Yep. And he's leaving in Jim's car. In Jim's car. And he tells everyone they can leave early and Angela's like, no, they can't. I've been planning a party for weeks. Yeah. They can't leave early. And then he makes fun of her and he's like, you must be this tall. Or you may not ride the roller coaster. Shorty joke number three. That's my favorite one. That was my favorite. Jenna's like, Angela, I do not remember writing those. I don't think they were in the script. And I think Steve was just having fun. Well, after Michael and Jim leave, the competition is over and Dwight wins. He beats the computer.
迈尔斯用那种唱歌般的语调告诉大家他明天就会回来，你知道他那种标志性的边唱边说话的腔调。没错。而且他坐的是吉姆的车。坐吉姆的车。他告诉大家可以提前下班，而安吉拉却说，不行，他们不能走。我已经策划派对好几周了。对。他们不能提前走。然后他取笑她，说，你必须长到这么高。否则你不能坐过山车。矮子笑话之三。我最喜欢这个。那是我最喜欢的。珍娜就像是，安吉拉，我不记得自己写过这些台词。我觉得它们根本不在剧本里。我觉得史蒂夫当时只是在即兴发挥。好吧，在迈尔斯和吉姆离开后，比赛结束了，德怀特赢了。他打败了电脑。
Like you said, Angela, he is really does not get the attention he deserves from this company. He beat a computer. Yeah. I mean, yes, he had to use the stolen leads, but he beats a computer. He beat the computer. Andy starts blowing this bear horn like crazy. And Angela is not having it. She's just like, just stop it. Well, when I watched this episode with Lee, at the end of it, he said, I have one question. Did that bear horn really make a sound? Or did they put that in in post? Okay, well, here is my memory of this particular moment. Now, I don't know about the other moments where it went off. But in this moment where I walked by, I was just supposed to walk by and sort of like glare at them and cruise on past. And that whole thing where I'm like,
就像你说的，安吉拉，他确实没有得到这家公司应得的关注。他打败了一台电脑。对。我是说，是的，他不得不使用偷来的线索，但他打败了一台电脑。他打败了电脑。安迪开始疯狂地吹起这个气喇叭。而安吉拉根本不吃这一套。她只是说，够了，住手。好吧，当我跟李一起看这一集时，看到最后，他说，我有一个问题。那个气喇叭真的发出声音了吗，还是后期配音加上去的？好吧，对于这个特定的时刻，我是这样记忆的。现在，我不知道其他按响喇叭的时刻是怎样的。但在我走过去的这一刻，我本该只是走过去，然后有点像瞪他们一眼，然后大摇大摆地走过去。而我一把夺过喇叭的那整段，也就是我说，
give me that, give it. That was all improvised. Because Andy, well, Ed is Andy, it's just kind of having fun with that thing. He's like, he's doing a dance. And so I had to grab at it a few times to get it. So I just sort of improvised all of that. And I can tell you, he was really shooting it off in that moment. I told Lee, my memory is that they gave Ed a bear horn. And Ed had a great time with it. I remember it going off constantly. This reminded me of when they gave Rain the keyboard in the dundies. Yes, do not give these guys things that make sounds. No, no props that make noises, they cannot stop using them. It was really funny. So yeah, I was just supposed to walk by and just kind of grab it and give them a look. And that's like me legitimately
拿来，给我。那全都是即兴发挥。因为安迪，呃，扮演安迪的爱德（Ed）当时只是在那个东西上找点乐子。他就像是在跳舞。所以我不得不伸手去抢了好几次才拿到。所以我基本上都是即兴发挥的。我可以告诉你，他在那一刻是真的在吹那个喇叭。我告诉李，我的记忆是他们确实给了爱德一个气喇叭。而爱德玩得很开心。我记得它一直在响。这让我想起了他们在《邓迪奖》（The Dundies）里给雷恩（Rain）键盘时的情景。是的，千万别给这几个人能发出声音的东西。不，千万别给他们制造噪音的道具，他们会停不下来地用。真的太搞笑了。所以，是的，我本来只是应该走过去，然后顺手一把夺过它，并给他们一个眼神。那就是我货真价实地
trying to grab it out of Ed's hand, like give it, give it here. Well, now we cut to the car where Michael and Jim are driving to New York City. And I noted something in this scene. Was it was it when Michael blew a kiss to Pennsylvania? Will he blew a kiss one for him and one for Jan? I know, I thought it was the cutest thing. My kids whenever we leave a city say goodbye to the city if we're driving. Yeah, we wave goodbye. Like if we're driving to the beach or up to the mountains or like goodbye Los Angeles. Goodbye beach. And to me, it was this very sweet childlike moment of Michael. Well, I'll say the moment that struck me in the car was when Michael says to Jim, you should come over for dinner on Friday night. Oh, girl. Oh, girl. I was like,
试图从爱德手里把它抢过来，就像是“拿来，给我”。好吧，现在镜头切到车上，迈尔斯和吉姆正开车前往纽约市。我在这个场景里注意到了一件事。是不是迈尔斯向宾夕法尼亚飞吻的那次？他飞吻了一个给自己，一个给珍。我知道，我觉得这太可爱了。我的孩子们每次离开一个城市时，如果我们在开车，都会跟这座城市说再见。对，我们会挥手告别。就像如果我们开车去海滩，或者去山里，或者像“再见，洛杉矶。再见，海滩”。对我来说，这是迈尔斯非常甜蜜、充满童心的一个时刻。好吧，我要说，车里最让我印象深刻的时刻是迈尔斯对吉姆说，你周五晚上应该来家里吃晚饭。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。我当时就想，
ding, ding, ding. It's coming. Dinner party is coming. And also that deleted scene you talked about where Michael and Jan were on the phone and she's like, we should make a roast this Friday. All of these things. I feel like that's planting a seed for her also Boko. Is that how you say it? Also Boko. Her five hour. Yeah. With no with no snacks out. Who does that? Who doesn't offer a cheese plate? We'll discuss later get there. Yeah, well, we will have a lot of discussion about it. But I felt like this planted the seed this idea that Michael was going to want Jim and Pam to come over for dinner. Michael has also purchased a gift for Ryan. He wanted to get Ryan. Oh, the places you'll go by Dr. Seuss, but it wasn't available. So he got green eggs and ham. It's kind of the
叮，叮，叮。要来了。晚宴派对要来了。还有你之前提到的那个被删减的片段，迈尔斯和珍在电话里，她说，我们这周五应该做个烤肉。所有这些事情。我觉得这也在为她的“阿博科”（Abo-ko）埋下伏笔。那是你怎么发音的？A-bo-ko。她的那个五个小时的——对。而且连点零食都没有。谁会这么干？谁会不提供一盘奶酪？我们稍后再讨论，到了再说。对，好吧，我们以后会对此有很多讨论。但我感觉这就埋下了伏笔，暗示迈尔斯会想让吉姆和帕姆来家里吃晚饭。迈尔斯还给瑞恩买了一件礼物。他想给瑞恩买——苏斯博士的《噢，你要去的地方！》（Oh, the Places You'll Go!），但买不到。所以他买的是《绿鸡蛋和火腿》（Green Eggs and Ham）。这跟他说的其实也差不多。
same thing he says. And what is Ryan going to think when he opens this and it's green eggs and ham? I don't know. Also, oh, the places you will go is such a personal message to someone. And again, Michael doesn't have this kind of relationship with Ryan, but is convinced he does. Yeah. And also hasn't Ryan already gone to the places he'll go? Well, there's that. I don't know. Well, finally on this drive, Jim asks Michael for the exact address of the party. And Michael says it's at a bar called chat room. And there's a password to get in. And Jim's like, Michael, you were invited to the satellite party. That's our party. Well, first, he just pulls the car over. Yeah. As soon as he hears this, he's like,
而瑞恩打开看到是《绿鸡蛋和火腿》时会怎么想？我不知道。还有，《噢，你要去的地方！》对某人来说是一份非常私人的寄语。而且再次说明，迈尔斯和瑞恩根本没有这种关系，但他坚信自己有。对。而且瑞恩难道不是已经去过他要去的地方了吗？好吧，那是另一回事了。我不知道。好吧，最后在这个车程中，吉姆向迈尔斯询问派对的具体地址。而迈尔斯说它在一个叫“聊天室”（chat room）的酒吧里，而且进去需要密码。吉姆就说，迈尔斯，你受邀去的是卫星派对。那是我们的派对。好吧，首先，他直接把车靠边停下了。对。一听到这个，他就觉得，
I don't even need to hear anymore. He just starts slowing the car down and he's going to do a UE. He's like Michael. Yeah. And Michael is on the phone to Ryan. He's like, what do you mean? I'm already in the city. Part of the city. I'm in the city. How could you do this? He's so upset. He feels so rejected. Yeah. And he throws the book out the window. Yeah. He's not going to give that book to Ryan anymore. And now Michael is going to have to go back and celebrate this launch with the rest of the folks in the conference room, the losers at the satellite party. And Dwight is convinced that winning and beating the computer that Angela is going to be impressed. It's going to be the thing that turns the tide. She's going to want him back.
我甚至不用听下去了。他直接开始减速，准备掉头。他就像是“迈尔斯”。对。而迈尔斯正在给瑞恩打电话，他说，你什么意思？我已经进城了。城里的一部分。我在城里。你怎么能这样？他太心烦了。他觉得自己被拒绝了。对。然后他把书扔出了窗外。对。他再也不打算把那本书送给瑞恩了。现在迈尔斯不得不灰溜溜地回去，和会议室里的其他人——卫星派对上的那些失败者们——一起庆祝这次发布会。而德怀特坚信，只要赢得比赛、打败电脑，安吉拉就会对刮目相看。这将是力挽狂澜的关键。她会回心转意的。
And she is not impressed. In fact, she's annoyed by it. And she has a talking head where she's like, how do you tell someone it's over? You send them a notarized letter, right? But what if your ex is your notary? Yeah. It's really perplexing. And she makes a big to-do of going up to front reception and telling Pam that she would very much like to date a man. And if Pam could please set her up. And she says it loud enough for Dwight to hear. And then Dwight is just, he's just brokenhearted and Pam sees it. And so in this way that we have these little moments with Pam and Dwight, Pam sends him a little direct message as the computer congratulating him on his win and telling him that he is the superior being.
而她根本不为所动。事实上，她对此感到非常厌烦。有一个独白镜头，她说，你怎么才能跟一个人说一切都结束了？你得发一封经过公证的信，对吧？但如果你的前任就是你的公证人呢？对。这真的很让人头疼。她大张旗鼓地走到前台，告诉帕姆她非常想和一个男人约会，如果帕姆能帮她介绍的话。她说话的声音大到德怀特都能听见。于是德怀特整个人心碎了，而帕姆看在眼里。于是，就像平时帕姆和德怀特之间那些温馨的小时刻一样，帕姆以电脑的名义给他发了一条小私信，祝贺他获胜，并告诉他他才是高级生物。
But it doesn't help much. It doesn't. Dwight's heartbroken. Yeah. It's heartbroken. And that is the first part of launch party part one. Yes. Next week, we're going to see Angela's party in the conference room. And Michael is going to take the pizza delivery guy hostage. Michael's going to be Michael. Michael's going to be in rare form. And Andy is going to make a play for Angela. Yeah. Yeah. Good stuff next week. There's one runner in deleted scenes. Before we go, I wanted to tell you about Jenna, because I think you really should watch it. You would get a kick out of it. You personally, Jenna Fisher, love the character Toby. Yeah. You love Toby. And there is a Toby runner where he is taking an online,
但这并没有什么卵用。并没有。德怀特心碎欲绝。对。心碎欲绝。这就是《发布会（上）》的第一部分。对。下周，我们将看到会议室里的安吉拉派对。迈尔斯绑架了送披萨的外卖小哥。迈尔斯将还是那个迈尔斯。迈尔斯将展现他罕见的抓狂状态。安迪将对安吉拉展开追求。对。对。下周精彩内容不断。被删减的片段里还有一个支线。在我们离开前，我真想跟你讲讲，珍娜，因为我觉得你真的应该看一看。你会觉得非常有意思。你本人，珍娜·费舍尔，非常喜欢托比这个角色。对。你超爱托比。有一个关于托比的支线，他正在参加一个在线的、
like, driving driver's school course or something. And there's a series of scenes where we find out that Toby is a horrible driver. This is such a random runner. I know. It's not related to anything else. And Oscar has a great talking head talking about what it's like riding in a car with Toby. Anyway, apparently Toby is a horrible driver. And it just was so delightful. It made me laugh. They probably created that for Paul so that he didn't have to be in any of the main scenes. They created a reason that his character was off doing something independently so he could actually be in the writer's room. They would do that a lot. Yeah. So he was through this whole episode, Toby is taking this online driver's school course. And we find out what a crappy
类似于驾校课程的东西，有一系列场景让我们发现托比其实是个糟糕的司机。这个支线真是莫名其妙。我知道。跟其他任何事都没关系。奥斯卡有一段精彩的独白，讲述了坐托比的车是什么体验。总之，显然托比是个极其糟糕的司机。这真的太逗了。把我逗得哈哈大笑。他们可能是专门为保罗（Paul）创作这个剧情的，这样他就不用参与任何主要场景了。他们为他的角色创造了一个去干别的独立事情的理由，这样他就可以真正在编剧室里工作了。他们经常这么干。对。所以他在整集中都在上这个在线驾校课程。然后我们发现他是个多么烂的
driver he is. I love it. Well, guys, that was launch party part one. We'll be back next week with part two. Yeah. Look out, Denise Stimms. Look out. I don't think that Angela is going to win this one. I'm sorry. I don't know. I hate to tell you. Buffalo is going to show you up. All right. We'll see you next week. Bye, you guys. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwool, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubakow. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com.
司机。我太喜欢了。好吧，伙计们，这就是《发布会（上）》。我们下周将带着下半部分回归。对。当心了，丹尼斯·斯特姆。当心了。我觉得安吉拉这次赢不了。抱歉。我不知道。我真不想打击你。布法罗那边会把你们比下去的。好啦。我们下周见。再见，伙计们。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利联合制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔（Cody Fisher）。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·吉弗（Sam Kiefer）。我们的助理制作人是艾恩斯利·布巴科（Ainsley Bubakow）。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）的《橡皮树》。想要收听无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。
For a free one month trial of StitcherPremium, use code Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如需免费试用Stitcher Premium一个月，请使用优惠码Office。本集尚无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。